et c'est parti pour le conseil de classe
2 promet celle maires pourront servir
jean michel maire dans tpm paix c'est
avant tout un chroniqueur d'envergure
toujours classe et élégant que la
couille bleus pendant quinze jours
moi j'ai pris un fou en vendée ont mis
un élève qui a beaucoup redoubler pour
le plus grand plaisir de son professeur
principal avec lequel il n'est jamais
avare d'un petit compliment et que vous
êtes le génie le mozart du paf ça c'est
pas moi qui lis les odeurs vous êtes
vous êtes un senior de barras d'essayer
je trouve à jean-michel c'est aussi des
gros progrès en diction cette saison
malgré quelques rechutes
quelle image malheureux concrètes et je
pense que je peux gagner je suis
jean-mi un élève qui met de la bonne
humeur même si c'est souvent au
détriment du bon déroulé de la classe je
me battais une nuit avec un anaconda
navré d'accord anna combat comme ça
avant je me suis réveillé j'attends
qu'on me caresser essayer de faire une
bonne réflexion et une bonne
intervention passe mon tour alors
qu'elle note pour jour me
[Applaudissements]
c'est son conseil de classe il considéré
comme un des meilleurs élèves de tpm pc
celui qui était là dès le début c'est
maintenant mr marié turc à la peau
l'émission two way
qu'est-ce qui me vient comme premier
moto est moi ce que j'aime beaucoup ces
jours michel sais qui je t'envie
beaucoup là dessus c'est que tu assumes
tout bas c'est vrai etc et voilà j'aime
bien les gens qui sont en harmonie avec
eux mêmes et qui assume tout bravo ces
réglages aussi où je peux me permettre
d'assumer ce que j'ai pu de perspectives
de je suis pas carriériste suffit elle
plante non je n'ai pas de plan je suis
j'ai 57 ans je suis en fin de course
bon je me perds ma mort je suis un
groupe union donc bonne façon j'aspire
être à la retraite dont je dis pas ça
comme un regret je suis contente d'être
bientôt la retraite est donc maintenant
me permet de dire ce que je veux
maintenant par au moins 30 ans 9 ans twh
de ponctuel pas moi et moi je fais quoi
connard j'ai fait mon temps à vous de
bosser voilà la fête très bon bien mv
c'est à la fin j'ai mis 9 bâtir et
camille naftule a vu en moi j'aime bien
ça a fait tilt et il est il est humain
et les il est pareil à la télé que il ya
plutôt qu en mai mais il est non je te
trouve très humain je moi je regarde
souvent l'émission parce que je sais les
heures du matin je regarde le matin mois
mais fait avoir et je te trouve je te
trouve toujours pertinent même si est un
vrai problème de diction on a le même je
pourrai mais maintenant c'est que c'est
quelqu'un d'humainement cas de bonne
valeur j'aimerais me parle de cul tout
le temps en fait il a dit il a 57 ans
lui reste peu de temps mais ça c'est fou
de dire ça vous êtes encore très jeune
fille jeudi samson tristesse mais je ne
dis pas que dieu très bon
alors moi les gens me le jean-mi des
coulisses que j'adore qui a été là pour
moi quand je suis arrivé tout au début
je sais pas ce que je faisais là je me
posais beaucoup de questions il me dit
t'inquiète pas tu te pose pas de
questions c'est bien ce que tu fais
toujours bienveillant et vraiment vous
le voyez drôle là mais en coulisses
c'est encore pire et le jean-mi du
plateau qui réussit toujours ces
happenings on sait pas comment il fait
on l'en vie quand ils rentrent et qui
fabrique ça marche toujours
hilary là il a ce côté de faire des
blagues et il est vu qu'il est vulgaire
ils excellent dans un vulgaire c'est
l'élégance à vulgaire dans l'excès dans
l'élégance s'arrête pas et qu'on a
compris non mais on se rend pas compte
que maintenant
mine de rien il ya laurent baffie qui
fait des vannes et qu'on pardonne tout
et lui il fait les des vannes oc on lui
pardonne tout parce qu'il me fait super
bien et c'est le rescapé de france car
c'est vous l'avez dit riboud et moi je
te remercie de passer deux reporters de
guerre à la d'arcade de tous les soirs
de suite à mon poste merci mon jean
miche de tif et mathieu bourret gibon ça
me gêne non c'est vrai que ça me j'aime
j'aime pas les convives
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
moi j'ai en michel merde je t'aimais
bien quand j'étais téléspectateurs et
puis arrivé ici tu m'as beaucoup attaqué
dès le pied mais pas ma tête à moi
j'aime pas la tienne dans patate est ta
gueule on parlait de laurent baffie
c'est vrai que vous avez un point commun
alors c'est pas le talent c'est plutôt
la calvitie avait opéré par la même
chirurgie ça il voulait dit voilà il
n'est pas en fin de course quand même
attention parce que les prochaines tpm
paix à ce rythme c'est un peu la nex de
la maison de retraite de sucy en brie
réfléchissez deux secondes mois pour
toutes ces raisons j'ai décidé de mettre
une note ou avec en prenant en compte
les interventions que tu as fait
celle qui était pertinente et puis le
nom de vrais cheveux que tu as donc
j'essaie de te mettre la note de 1 à 10
me disent qu'ils pensent j'adore jean
marais barométrique très bonne note on
l'a le [ __ ] va tu vois je n'avais pas
de blerim et matthieu delormeau
oui je vais très honnête s'il ne devait
en rester qu'un enfin outre cascio nains
que vous ne pourriez pas perdre l'année
prochaine
parmi tous je suis désolé parmi tous
ceux que j'aime moi y compris le seul
que vous ne pourriez pas perdre pour
cette émission c'est jean michel maire
il est bon dans les débats pour les îles
et non il est très active et plus que la
plupart ici pardon il est très bon dans
les débats il est ce navet peur de
malades
il est drôle il est bon camarade ils
s'engueulent jamais avec vous il ne
refuse rien il fait des tournages en
dehors comme ce camp certains font un
peu la tête de con je ne cite personne
mais n'y vont pas non mais l'assurance
et mathieu voir ce qui ce qui est moche
insee mathieu fait vrai c'est vrai
il ya de l'amour mais il est bon
camarade
il est incroyable en dehors de la vie
pour ceux qui ne connaissent pas que tu
vas prendre quelque chose
si un soin et avec sa fille c'est même
pas la peine de sable de la mater sa
fille ce qui est le plus important au
monde
il a des vraies valeurs je lui ai fait
je vais donner des secrets qui n'a
jamais trahi contre régis légèrement
hier et un jour et demi à 4 ans était en
train de vie à mon meilleur ami c'était
trop tôt ça n'est l'amitié comme tout
quatre ans après il fait partie de mes
deux ou trois meilleurs amis et il est
exactement comme quand il fait l'amour
il est meilleur d'année en année il est
encore meilleur cette année dix ans
après alors on a presque aux côtés de
jean michel mr moitié nord mauvaise note
salée j'ai mis dix on dispose
allez vite castaldi écoutez difficile de
dire des choses négatives sur ce garçon
que j'aime beaucoup que j'ai appris à
connaître
on a un point commun on n'y apprend pas
tout ce qu'on dit donc j'étais parti sur
une excellente note le 9 mai comme on
comprend une phrase sur deux j'ai mis
quatre et demi de mêlée alors jean mi
quand on me demande quel est mon
chroniqueurs préférés j'assume je le dis
devant tout le monde j'ai dit à chaque
fois que c'est toi merci je t'aime
d'amour je t'aime vraiment beaucoup
je peux avoir beaucoup d'émotion quand
je parle de parce que parce que tu es
toujours là pour moi toujours été là
pour moi que sans la peau ni que ce soit
en tunisie était très protecteur et je
te remercierai jamais assez
vraiment je veux lui faire un bisou
bisou
[Applaudissements]
franchement ça elle adore boules de
sensibilité ouais ça c'est une quoi
dubaï de la neige mais tout gâché par ce
que ton côté suce boules m'insupporte
alors je te mets à 1,5 adore en laponie
antunes man latin moi c'est toujours le
premier est là pour moi ça s'arrose à
[Rires]
belmont unis bosque oui il est superbe
oui il est charmant oui il est bon
camarade oui il est généreux il m'a même
offert au chat lui qui par ailleurs me
traitent souvent des chattes
bonjour je laime vraiment oui on adore
bollène vraime de mamou faire un chameau
il est vraiment vraiment beaucoup cela
dit toi qui parle tout le temps de la
longueur du temps sec tu devrais aussi
parlé de la longueur du poil que tu as
dans la main presque franchement les
deux se valent pas et si la défaillance
mais c'est toujours se servir de moi je
t'aime beaucoup amusé lui son survival
que tu me prêtait souvent dieccte a
contredit crois que la retraite
alors pour tout ça vraiment je te mets
16gt lyon finira par la doyenne
non mais la doyenne gauche que de ddd
créateur a choisi car est adoptée très
compréhensibles par ailleurs
il a été très bon sur l'autel de classe
alors bout les points faibles il le dit
lui-même il ne travaille pas c'est pas
un bosseur
voilà il est et partage aussi avec
mathieu tout dans le culte de la
discussion dessous de la ceinture du
non-stop à la mer matic aussi à ouidah
au format nous raconter votre bail
d'ailleurs mais et 1.1 point fort en
tant que son voilà tout le passé de
journaliste politique correspondant de
guerre chroniqueur judiciaire voilà
chaque le chaque mot qui dit voilà ça
fuse et puis effectivement il aime la
dar k il supporte les tartes il supporte
tout est supporter de se déguiser
toujours en souriant la même humeur et à
voile à gérer pour tous à 7 et demi
alors ben ali mouassa bachand a mis ça
fait sept ans que je suis à 6 à quel âge
mais nous avons c'est la passion
excusait aziz sy alors c'est qui a fait
ça c'est vous avez mis ces gens mais je
le reconnais il a fait les défilés
monocouche d'or cotait alors attend que
ça fait sept ans que chez assise à côté
de jean-michel tous les soirs sacré de
la proximité je l'aimais infiniment il
le sait mais vraiment c'est voilà jeu de
tout mon coeur je t'aime jean michel tu
m'as vérifier extrêmement élégant tu est
extrêmement bien née et élevée qu'elle
est un garçon qui a beaucoup des
ducasses propres évidemment c'est un
glandeur manioc et en a fait une force
c'est à dire oui on pouvait être
reproché de ne pas connaître les invités
ne pas dire les lycées de ne pas voir
les films de ne pas voir les émissions
faites en a fait un truc de dingue hein
un atout et par dessus tout cette année
pas lâcher la rampe tata dit maintenant
c'est moi le sniper que - l'humoriste et
tu est extrêmement tu est indispensable
à l'émotion créée pour toutes ces
raisons et pour l'amour que je te porte
justement à 8 ha bon
obama a appelé cet après midi on vit
dans la minute sadi ne valait pas passer
en conseil de classe
en fait alors c'est intéressant parce
que bon il est parlé avec toi de la
dignité humaine de l'être humain est un
savant frassa après parce que je crois
est facile à jouer je sais c'est cruel
dans leur dignité d'être humain quand
même mais bon on y va alors j'ai noté de
suite j'ai noté des trucs qui m'ont fait
penser à toi j'ai dit il ne joue pas
contre sa propre équipe
oui il ne marque pas contre son propre
camp c'est la même chose
il a le sens du sacrifice si cyril à un
problème dû se jette avec une blague
balourde mais c'est pas grave
au moins il a sauvé son pote oui il
n'essaye pas de faire plus vite ou mieux
que les autres il a une bonne mentalité
et esprit d'équipé my brother mon blake
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
huit sur dix ans que jean michel mr
aulas donc la note globale et on va voir
la note des tweetos également merci en
régie c'est parti des chroniques il
regarde les faits aujourd'hui je vais te
dire le sondage on va le voir dans un
instant qu est à dire toi mon cher
bah non mais c'est vrai que j'ai une
certaine facilité si je suis là depuis
la première donc j'ai l'impression de
faire partie des meubles quand j'arrive
ici c'est je viens pas au travail
j'arrive dans ma deuxième famille dont
va quand on est en famille on est
toujours à l'aise donc c'est plus facile
d'être bon truc dit mais quand on est à
l'aise voilà moi je crois ici c'est pas
un boulot si je prends je prends un bout
un plaisir énorme et chaque année un peu
plus
donc j'espère que je serai encore
l'année prochaine parce que la cilam
fermé voilà en tout cas un grand plaisir
un grand plaisir à être là et voilà donc
les ans des gens ccd ou sur ma biche oh
mais je regarde j'attends des notes
gardena et c'est la première fois que tu
as travaillé j'ai envie d'appeler les
gens en dehors de mon travail
alors voilà pour savoir comment ils vont
et cetera arrêtez donc quand je pars je
vois je fais fuir les gens quand je
parlais je vais les ambiances mais oui
mais moi aussi je vous ai même chocolat
non non non mais alors parce que et une
baie comme thème bien connu
aujourd'hui tu sais que je t'aime et je
donnerai mon appréciation bien sûr vide
et tu étais heureux d'être là et bien
sûr chaque année un peu plus mais nous
aussi
voilà il a fugué d'airness à celle
d'hier alors s 83
g
jean mimi
alors que maintenant de la mouillère et
quitte à 62 2 %
voilà donc voilà les décide je reconnais